- [Instructor] We're asked
which two of the following
expressions have the same value as 8.76?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure this out
on your own.
All right now let's do it together.
Before I even look at these
choices, I'm just going
to really understand what
this number represents
and let me just rewrite it.
So we have 8.76 so there's
a couple of ways we could
think about it, we can look
at our place values, this
right over here this is the
ones place, this right over here
this is the tenths place,
and this right over here
is the hundredths, hundredths place.
And so we could view this as
eight ones and seven tenths
and six hundredths or eight
ones plus seven tenths
plus six hundredths.
Well that's exactly what
they wrote right over here.
Eight ones, seven tenths, and
six hundredths, so I would
choose that one for sure.
Now this second choice
looks like an expanded form,
but before I even look at
it let's see how we would
think about it over here.
If we wanted to essentially
write the same idea
but in expanded form, eight
ones is the same thing
as eight times one and
actually let me color code it
so you see where things are coming from.
So eight ones that's the
same thing as eight times one
and to that we would add
seven tenths, so that's plus
seven times 1/10 so seven
tenths plus and I'll do this
in this orange color, six
hundredths so that's plus
six times a hundredth, six hundredths.
So this would be this number
in expanded form is that
what they put right over here,
yes it is indeed what they
put right over here, so
I will circle that in.
Now if you're doing this on
your own we know that we just
picked two answers, but
let's see whether these other
forms or let's see if we can
write this in these other
forms and see how these might
not be the exact answer.
So if we were to write
this out and take out each
of the decimal parts, so the
eight ones you'd just write
that as eight, the seven
tenths, seven tenths well that
would be plus 0.7 this is
seven tenths right over here,
this and this and this part
right over here are all
equivalent and then last
but not least you have your
six hundredths, so plus so
that's our ones, that's our
tenths, and then we're in our
hundredths place and we're
going to have six of them.
So this would be equal to our
original value but that's not
what they wrote over here,
they did write eight ones,
they did write seven tenths,
but they did not write six
hundredths, they wrote
six thousandths here.
So we could rule that one out.
And then if we were to write
it out in words we would say
this is eight eight and
do and in a neutral color,
now you might say and seven
tenths and six hundredths,
or you could often what's
normally is you express it
in the lowest place that
you have or the most precise
place that you have so you
could do seven tenths as 70
hundredths or you could view,
you could view this whole
thing as 76 hundredths so
it could be eight and 70,
70 six hundredths, hundredths.
But what they wrote over
here they did write eight
but instead of 76 hundredths,
they wrote eight and 67
hundredths a little tricky
so we would rule that one
out as well.